when i lose i say that i deserve it i
think i deserve it i made a mistake i
was wrong about the market i was wrong
about a person i was wrong the quickest
way for me to judge somebody who i know
is not going to win long term is their
ability to blame others i believe if we
make accountability super cool it will
lead to enormous amounts of happiness
everything that's a problem with me
everything i don't achieve everything
that's a problem at vaynermedia
everything is my fault and i i succumb
to that and i respect that and i
actually think that's the way it should
be no excuses my friends you want to get
really happy actually understand that
the things that bother you are your
fault and then if you can actually be
accountable but not then demonize
yourself i am very aware of many things
i do wrong but they don't make me feel
like a piece of [ __ ] like you know it's
just one of those things but the problem
is the reason a lot of people don't want
to be accountable is the second they
think they suck they go into depression
and i'm like no no you don't suck you're
just not good at this thing where you
did that wrong or that was not a nice
thing to do or that was actually
terrible to do